so what do you think about this game
what's what a monster it's delicious
everything about connect I think it's
challenging because I have no arms or
legs and your mouth full of cookies yeah
well that's right dive into a storybook
adventure like no other full of beauty
full of surprises
full of discovery
full of monsters Sesame Street what's on
a cupcake is a monster what's the
monster is a new game from double fine
productions that we were making with a
sesame workshop it's Warner Brothers
using Kinect to let kids interact with
those stores look full of friendly
monsters and it was the idea of mr.
Mercer Nathan Marx who was a programmer
of brutal legend one of our big
inspirations actually even before we
knew that we'd be working with sesame
workshop was Jim Henson someone whose
creativity and enormous influence on my
life and on Tim's life but i think
really showed how to create original
loveable characters and especially
monsters so the game from its Genesis
was about monsters over time we learned
about connect and felt like that would
be an exciting thing to bring into the
product we realize it could be a great
way to for not just for adults to have
fun but for adults and kids to have fun
together and then finally working with
Warner Brothers and sesame workshop
we've got to work with this incredible
property Sesame Street and bring connect
Double Fine monsters and Sesame Street
monsters together in a single package
usually when people think about Sesame
Street they think not just educational
but they think numeracy and literacy
that's a huge part of the bread and
butter of Sesame Street but actually
Sesame Street is about a lot more than
that and they have a whole other aspect
of their curriculum it's called the
whole child curriculum which is about
social and emotional development it's
about healthy habits for life about
eating well about being physically
active it's also about taking care of
your environment having an appreciation
for the world around you and it's
actually that part of their curriculum
that's the focus of Once Upon a monster
but if we're educational we're teaching
things actually not just showing you
what the right answer is providing the
player an opportunity to help the
monsters to model good behavior back at
the game and we hope that some people
enjoy and save the a long division for
the DLC yeah exactly
you